tal vez la idea más alucinante en toda
la biología es que todos los seres vivos
que conocemos hasta el día de hoy claro
con base en la evidencia actual que se
tiene se dice que todos tienen su origen
en un ancestro en común así que no
importa si hablamos de una célula
bacteriana simple que bueno en realidad
no es tan simple después de todo o si
hablamos de un árbol hecho de miles de
millones de células un primate peludo
también hecho de miles de millones de
células o incluso unos gatitos
agricultores muy bien vestidos que
también están hechos de miles de
millones de células todos comparten un
ancestro en común y tal vez ya hayan
visto un árbol filogenético como éste
que nos muestra que todo lo que se
encuentra en el mundo hasta el día de
hoy todos los seres vivos sin importar
su dominio porque por ejemplo nosotros
somos un subconjunto de animales y
existen muchas especies animales no
importa todos compartimos un ancestro en
común que existió hace muchos
miles de millones de años pero tenemos
que ser escépticos porque recuerden que
aquí somos científicos como creemos esto
cuál es la evidencia
bueno una evidencia la podemos encontrar
al observar el nivel celular de los
organismos y buscar las similitudes que
existen entre los diferentes grupos para
darnos cuenta de que es poco probable
que se hubieran desarrollado de forma
independiente unos de otros por ejemplo
todas las formas de vida que conocemos
tienen adn también todas tienen a rn y
no es solamente a hablar de cómo
codifican la información sino que
también podemos hablar de los procesos
porque comparten los mismos procesos
bioquímicos que ocurren en las células
como por ejemplo en todas ocurre alguna
forma de glucosa sis
pero parece que estas no son las únicas
similitudes que se han encontrado en
todos los seres vivos porque además
todos tienen una célula como unidad más
básica y están envueltos por una
membrana así que en teoría los distintos
organismos pudieron haberse desarrollado
de forma independiente unos de otros sin
tener un ancestro en común pero tener un
ancestro en común es la mejor
explicación del porqué existen todos
estos procesos tan diferentes y muchos
de ellos son muy complejos para todas
las distintas formas de vida como las
conocemos y tal vez me diga ok te creo
que hubo un ancestro en común pero como
se construyó este árbol cómo podemos
saber cuando se formaron las
ramificaciones bueno estás
ramificaciones en el árbol evolutivo
ocurrieron hace cientos de millones de
años y ninguno de nosotros existimos
para observarlo pero eso nos lleva a más
de evidencia estructural fíjense que
entre los organismos que ahora
clasificamos como eucario
o también conocidos como eucariontes es
decir todo lo de color café todos estos
organismos en esta rama del árbol tienen
organelos rodeados por una membrana
organelos o también conocidos como
orgánulos contenidos por membrana que
son cosas como el núcleo o las
mitocondrias que ya hemos estudiado en
otros vídeos y también todos tienen
cromosomas lineales así que en los otros
grupos de este árbol de la vida en este
árbol evolutivo tal vez se encuentren
con cromosomas circulares pero algo que
es común en todas las eucariotas son los
cromosomas lineales y todos tienen
cromosomas que contienen intrones los
intrones son secuencias de adn que no
codifican a genes sino que codifican a
proteínas y aún se está explorando cuál
es el punto de los intrones pero la
razón por la que todos estos organismos
forman parte de una misma clasificación
es porque todas
en estas similitudes por eso creemos que
formaron su propia ramificación entonces
con base en las similitudes podemos
formar una teoría sobre cuando se
ramificaron los organismos vivos y ahora
que ya existen herramientas más
sofisticadas de secuenciación de adn y
arn podemos ver qué tan distintas son
las secuencias y así poder construir
árboles más y más precisos como éste